this last book I wrote about anxiety I
ended up leaving my family for a week
and I went to a hotel and checked in and
had to write myself out and I spent time
in the hotel gym and in front of a
computer 24 hours a day for a week
I went crazy
but I never gave up on myself I didn't
give up on my wife I didn't give up on
my kids
I didn't give up on my community or my
friends or my job I kept going and
sometimes it was one tiny tiny little
step in front of the other but I didn't
quit and so did that disqualify me from
for helping people with emotional mental
health no
because I'm I'm on the same path as
everybody else is in fact it I think it
gives me some empathy and it gives me
some understanding when somebody calls
you and says hey man I don't know which
way to turn you can go dude I know